تحت عنوان شاه عمري لاول مره زوج يقيم
دعوه قضائيه ضد زوجته بالتعسف في استخدام
الحق في طلبها للخلع بالفعل زوج رفع دعوى
قضائيه يطالب فيها زوجته بالتعويض المدني
على خلفيه اتهامها بالتعسف استقدام الحق
في طلبها للخلع بعد ذلك ذلك قامت اقامت هي
الدعوه الخلع بعد كم سنه بعد ثلاثين عاما
من الحياه الزوجيه واستولت على ممتلكاته
التي قضى عمره في تحصيلها في الخارج لمده
خمسه عشره سنه ثم
قالت الله وياك خلعتها هذه دعوه تعد من
الدعوه والمقامه لاول مره في المحاكم
المصريه بالفعل عادل ما كان هناك اي طبعا
قضايا سابقه من هذا النوع بحسب ننسى
القانون المصري فان الخلع واقع بقضاء
القاضي ولا يحق للزوج الاعتراض عليه طيب
حكم الخلق هو حكم نهائي للسينافي اصبح
واقعا يعيش الزوج من حين اعلانه استلام
الحكم المذكور لكن الزوج هنا استند في
دعواه القضائيه على القانون المدني وحكم
سابق لمحكمه النقد كيف فاز كيف يستفيد كيف
[موسيقى]
فاذا مشاهدينا سالنا الناس في لبنان حق
خلع الزوج متى يتحول الى استغلال خلونا
نشوف شو قالوا
[موسيقى]
هلا عن جديد ديرجة بصير انه المراه عم
تتطلع على السوشيال ميديا عم تطلع على عم
تلحق عم تضعف نفسها على هالاشياء وعلى
هالارباح اللي عم تجيهم من الانترنت ومن
السوشيال ميديا الله في عندك عده حالات
يعني كرمال الموضه فيها تترك وتتخلى عنه
الزوج تمشي لحالها مثلا بتلحق حدا موضه
جديده طالعه هون الزوج ما حدا بده اياه
انه بس والله اذا جوزها بمطرح من المطارح
يعني بوضعه الماده والله انه انا ما
معجبني هيك بدي واحد يصرف علي كذا بتخلع
كان حبه حدا ثاني او مثلا
ما بقت تحبه لجاوزها او شيء بتطلب او
بتشترك هي وحبيبه انه يعملوا له مشكل
لا يتركه يعني الماديه هالايام تلعب كثير
بين الزوج والزوجة خصوصا بنات هالاي ام
يعني اجمالا 3/4 بيسعوا ورا هيدا الشي من
ورا الماده استغلال الزوجه لزوجها بسبب
الطلاق اول شيء الخيانه طبعا اكيد وقلت
المصاري
والمعامله بقلب البيت طبعا هذا كله بياثر
لطلاق من الابل للمراه انه تخلع جوزها
طيب ينضم الينا من الخارج الدكتور اسامه
الفقهي الاستاذ بجامعه
القاهره والمدرب الدولي المعتمد اهلا بك
دكتور يعني بدايه خليني اسالك
اهلا وسهلا بحضرتك الخلع بالنسبه للمراه
اذا كان ثمه ضرر فهو حق ولكن متى يعتبر
استغلال للرجل والرجل هنا يكون
المستغله والمستضعف
ورغم ان احنا دائما مستعظيم السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته وعليكم السلام
صباح الخير على قناه العربيه
خالص تحياتي للساده المشاهدين الكرام
بالنسبه لسؤال حضرتك طبعا هو في فرق بين
الخلع وفي فرق بين الطلاق فالطلاق هو ان
الزوج كره الحياه مع زوجته وهنا الامر
بيكون بايد الزوج نفسه انما بالنسبه للخلع
فهو من الزوجه هي اللي كرهت الحياه مع
زوجها وفي الحاله دي هي اللي بتطلب
الانفصال او انهاء العلاقه الزوجيه وفي
الحالتين في انهاء للعلاقه الزوجيه في
حاله الطلاق الزوج بيعطي للزوجه كل
مستحقاتها ومتفق وما اتفق عليه بينهم
وبيتم الطلاق بالتراضي انما في حاله الخلع
الزوجه هي اللي بتعطي بتعطي لزوجها
الصداقه اللي اتقدمه لها واي هدايا يقدمه
لها وعلشان ايه يتم الانفصال حقوقها
بالظبط كده في الحالتين دول بيكون انتهاء
فهنا بيكون انتهاء للعلاقه الزوجيه
المفروض في حل الحادثه اللي احنا بنسمعها
دلوقتي دي
لو كان في طمع او استغلال او حاجه زي كده
ما بيكونش بقى 30 سنه من الزواج لان انا
سامع ان حضرتكم بتقولوا ان هو قاعد 30 سنه
هنا ان الموضوع هنا في الحلقه دي هو موضوع
كراهيه متراكمه على مدار سنين طويله قوي
وجاء الوقت اللي هي ابتدت تنتقم منه في
سوره الخلق او في سوره الانتقام باخذ
الاموال وبكل الحاجات دي اسمح لي شويه هلا
في حالات كثير وحالات طلاق بتصير بعد عقود
من الزواج وبكون يعني الهدف منها مش
الاستغلال والطمع وما الى ذلك في ناس
مضطره انها ظروفها ما كانت تسمح لها
للطلاق في اطفال كانوا صغار استنوا على
كبروا فبالتالي مش بالضروره ان يكون في
سوق نيه من وراء الخلع في كل مره اللي بدي
اساله هو هل بالضبط قانونيه فيما يتعلق
بقضايا الخلع تحط تضع حد لهذا الاستغلال
لانه على علمي انه يعني عندما تطلب المراه
الخلع
ستتخلى عن حقوقها فبالتالي يعني لا مكان
للطمع في هذا الموضوع هي فقط تريد حريتها
[موسيقى]
بالضبط هو الخلع ليس في مجال للطمع
وبالضبط كده
يعني عايز اقوله ان هم ماسكوش الصبح كانوا
امبارح متعشيين كويس بس دكتور يعني اذا
تكرمت اليوم القضيه اكيد صح بس اذا هو هو
ربما عمل وهذه الاموال كانت ترسل من
الخارج الى زوجته اشترت فيها شقه باسمها
هذا هذا لن يعتبر حق وتتنازل عنه للزوج
سيعتبر ملك لها باعتبار انه الفلوس اللي
هو بعثها
طيب هذا الزوج المستغل بين قوسين كيف يمكن
ان يتاقلم مره ثانيه مع هذا المجتمع
وبالتالي اليس من حق الطعن على هذا
القانون
انا مش قانوني لا لا انا يعني انا اقصد
اجتماعيا نفسيا
اجتماعيا بالضبط كده الاسره اللي هي
بتتكون من زوج وزوجه دول الخليه الاولى
للمجتمع كويس مع الوقت مع الوقت بيكون في
بعض المشاكل اللي بتحصل بين الزوجين
المشاكل دي بيغيب عنها المصارحه
ويتاخر فيها المصالحه المصالحه يعني ايه
يعني لما تحصل مشكله بين الزوجين لازم
الاثنين يتكلموا مع بعض يسالها ايه اللي
مزعلك ايه اللي مزعلني واحد اتنين تلاته
يبداوا يصارحوا بعض بكل حاجه مضايقك تاني
وبالتالي يحصل الذوبان للمشاكل دي اولا
باول ما تتراكمش تراكمها ده وبيتكون في
النفس ضغينه وكره مع الوقت بيجي اللحظه
الانفجار بيحصل وتيجي الزوجه بتطلب
الانفصال وتبدا تنتقم هي لما اخذت الفلوس
دي وخدت الشقه والحاجات دي ليس طمع بقدر
ما هو انتقام المراه بطبيعتها طبيعتها
اللي ربنا خلقها عليها عطوفه وحنونه
وجميله وطيبه انما لما بيوصل لوقت كويس
وفي
لان هي بتبقى الزوجه حضرتك اكتر واحده
حريصه على استقرار البيت ده احنا قبلنا
على كده ونشانا على كده واي دي بالفطره
الانثى بالطلاق مباشره وتتاخر على بين ما
توصل اولادها لبر الامان على كل حال
لانها بتصبر مره واتنين وتلاته وسنه
واثنين وثلاثه ويحصل الانفجار مش هتاره
الزوج انه ما يسمحش بالانفجار ده يحصل
شطاره الزوج انه دائما يزود
ويذوب المشاكل اولا باول
ففي
المعتمد كان معنا من الخرج للاسف انتهى
وقت انا بس بدي اقول شغله واحده يا عادل
المراه والرجل مش فريقين بيلعبوا ضد بعض
المفروض انه لاعبين نلعب بنفس الفريق على
الاقل انا بطلع انا بالحكم نكون منصب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات